president Trump will head to Capitol
Hill tomorrow to talk about immigration
policy with congressional Republicans
this comes as GOP leaders hope to take
action on immigration reform legislation
this week and put an end to an issue
that threatens to turn into a public
relations disaster as previously
explained chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel is on Capitol
Hill tonight the zero tolerance
immigration policy is now making some
Republicans on Capitol Hill
uncomfortable it's clear this is a very
sympathetic tugs at your heartstrings
sort of picture and narrative but I
think there's it's it's a little more
complicated than that it is inconsistent
with our American values that separate
these children from their parents
Collins in Arizona Republican Senator
Jeff Flake sent this letter to the
secretaries of Homeland Security and
Health and Human Services riding cars
must know how the nation's laws are
being implemented quote especially when
the well-being of young children is at
stake there's also pressure from the
left California Democrat Senator Dianne
Feinstein has offered a bill to ban
separating families I never thought the
United States of America would be
separating children from their parents
infants from their parents nursing
mothers from their infants it's terrible
and we've got to stop it president Trump
met today with Republican senators
Richard Shelby and Shelley Moore Capito
with mr. Trump wanting funding for his
border wall and she'll be trying to pass
funding bills in a bipartisan fashion
across the Capitol House lawmakers are
expected to consider two different
immigration reform plans this week a
conservative measure from Judiciary
Chairman Bob Goodlatte and a carefully
crafted compromise based on president
Trump's or pillars it's gotten border
security in there it's got funding for
the wall the president really wants it's
got the technology and boots on the
ground
the president's expected to meet with
House Republicans tomorrow night to
personally make the case for addressing
illegal immigration McCall says
lawmakers must get it done the threats
as I get briefed by the secretary and
the ice director a potential terrorists
and drug cartels and all the other stuff
is real on the issue of separating
children from their
parents Texas senator Ted Cruz has just
introduced emergency legislation
it calls for hiring more border
immigration judges building temporary
shelters to keep the families together
and for families that are determined
that should not get Asylum deporting
them within two weeks we'll see if
that's the fix Brett Mike another issue
what about the pending showdown between
President Trump and the Senate over
Chinese telecom firm ZTE well Bret
president Trump has his plan to help
revive ZTE the Chinese telecom giant the
Senate even the president's allies is
looking to block that deal they had at
the included language inside a giant
defense authorization bill that's coming
up for a vote in the Senate this evening
lawmakers are not interested in reviving
a company that has been alleged to work
with both Iran and North Korea and so
definitely a showdown between the US
Senate and the President on the ZTE
issue Bret I will follow that my command
will live on the hill Mike thanks